Peggy 18
hi I'm Sean Hamburg the executive
producer for Mortal Kombat X today it's
my honor to get to reveal the tattooed
sorcerer Quan Chi plays a major part in
the MKX story let's take a look at him
now
Quan Chi is a master manipulator and in
MKX his schemes are fully realized using
his necromancer powers Quan Chi has
built an army of revenant from the
fallen of Rome warriors twisting their
minds to fight on his behalf
Quan Chi is an unforgiving denizen of
the nether room and for this battle
we're going to match him up against
someone just as evil Cana in the story
of MKX we'll find out if these two evil
characters can work together for a
common goal or if they have other more
sinister agenda
I do worse sorcerer you shall see my
worst marked sorcerer Quan Chi casts a
variety of spells of occupy targeted
areas within the arena some spells and
hands Quan Chi's special moves allowing
him to cause more damage while others
weaken is apart
the Warlock variation allows Quan Chi to
open interdimensional dark portals
already a trickster on the battlefield
these portals of den quan chi's attacks
and special moves to create
unpredictable combos
and of course as a powerful demon
himself Quan Chi can use his summoner
variation to conjure demonic beasts from
the nether realm to fight by his side
finish